well it looks like the Marvels has made
a major change to their ending in fact
it sounds like from what we've heard
whatever change that they have made to
the ending of the film is a complete
GameChanger and could actually take the
movie Up A Notch and it sounds like they
actually could have added a pretty
decent sized Cameo to the ending of the
Marvels what is going on everybody
welcome back to the cosmic wonder I'm
Warren Thompson and the Marvels has a
lot of Buzz surrounding it right now but
not necessarily all in the best way a
lot of us are really really hoping that
this movie turns out well that it's
going to be a good movie However
unfortunately the movie already has a
lot of hate people expect it to fail
it's got crazy high box office numbers
to hit to break even and it's incredibly
short right now the latest that we've
heard about its runtime is that it's set
at 1 hour and 45 minutes this would make
it the shortest MCU film ever beating
the Incredible Hulk and Thor the Dark
World at 1 hour and 52 minutes however
this new addition to the ending might
change the runtime and from what we've
heard they've altered the ending to make
it connect with Secret Wars even more so
now we've already heard a little bit
about the original ending and it was
indeed going to kind of connect to
Secret Wars in a pretty decent way but
according to some of these insiders it's
going to connect even more now so of
course we're going to dive into what
they've said and break it all down and
of course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest the Marvel news and of
course MCU news and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items as well
the winner picks one item and we pick a
winner at the end of each month only
about a week to go so the first report
is seemingly coming from Grace Randol
who states on Twitter rumor has it they
added a last minute surprise to the
Marvels beware spoilers she then went on
to State this is a new surprise that
hasn't leaked yet I'm not even 100% sure
what it is now of course people are
talking and the rumors have already
begun talking about what this could be
and we have some ideas but first let's
hear what the other insiders are stating
cryptic 4K qual who has a 100% track
record right now with Scoops States this
just going to say from what I saw back
then to now that ending is a very big
last minute change the F2 two additional
tickets bought for the Marvels so
cryptic 4K qual implies that this change
is so good that additional tickets were
bought for the movie whether this person
was going to see the movie originally or
not it sounds like they definitely are
now implying that this very big change
is very good and to top it all off
another Insider can we get some toast
tweeted this it's true everything's
starting to connect they then posted a
picture of the poster for the Marvels
the logo logo for Deadpool 3 and the
logo for Avengers Secret Wars implying
and telling us that the Marvel's ending
will directly connect to Deadpool 3 and
Avengers Secret Wars now we already kind
of knew a little bit about what the
ending for the Marvels was supposed to
be no super huge spoilers in this but
from what we've heard there's supposed
to be an incursion happening towards the
end of the film we're not sure if they
stopped this incursion from happening or
not but from what we've heard one of the
characters of the movie is supposed to
wind up in another universe so here's
our theory of what could happen if the
Marvels is supposed to connect to
Deadpool 3 and Avengers Secret Wars then
we could be seeing a cameo possibly from
a fox X-Men Universe which means we
could possibly see an X-Men Cameo if
Captain Marvel or Monica Rambo or Kamala
Khan end up in another Universe perhaps
they could be greeted by a fox X-Men
director of Deadpool 3 Shan Levy has
pretty much already stated yes there are
going to be cameos in Deadpool 3 and no
we are not going to ignore the past Fox
Xmen universe es so he pretty much said
yes there are going to be X-Men cameos
plus not to mention Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine's going to be in the film and
we got to imagine we're going to visit
the universe where he's from which of
course is the fox X-Men universe so
perhaps a character from the Marvels
ends up in that Universe perhaps we see
a wolverine Cameo or a Professor X
Magneto it could be anybody and it could
be Deadpool himself now of course this
is just a theory this is not confirmed
in any way whatsoever but if we are
talking about what could create a lot of
hype for the Marvels to go out and get
people to see it which is what Marvel
Studios is trying to do right now then
teasing some of the original X-Men
returning in Deadpool 3 would be a great
way to do it and it would greatly
benefit not only the movie but the MCU
in general and of course Deadpool 3
itself the hype for the Marvel's
unfortunately isn't the best it could be
the cast is currently on the sidelines
and cannot promote the film due to the
strikes happening right now and of
course like I've mentioned unfortunately
a lot of the hate for the first Captain
Marvel film in Brie Larson has bled over
so we know that Marvel Studios right now
is looking for some type of way to
increase the hype for the movie and this
is honestly a pretty good way to do it
change the ending slightly that way word
gets out about the ending being changed
and that Sparks people's curiosity and
then put a pretty good cameo in the
ending that makes people kind of freak
out about it so by doing this one people
will want to go see the marbles because
they're going to want to go see the
Cameo even if you've heard what the
Cameo is you're still wanting to go see
it if it's Deadpool if it's professor
Xavier if it's perhaps something like
Robert Downey Jr being Iron Man in a
different Universe you're going to want
to go see it even if you already know
what it is so that way even if you had
no interest in seeing the Marvels
whatsoever you'll still go show up to
watch that movie just to see that Cameo
at the end it's a good plan then at the
same time by possibly showing a
different variant From Another Universe
that increases the hype of the MCU in
general some fans have kind of
complained that we're in the Multiverse
Saga but a lot of it doesn't feel really
that connected and we haven't really
dove into variants that much yet and
universes haven't really crossed over
that much we've really only seen it in
Spider-Man no way home and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness but
even those movies weren't on the scale
that we would have liked to have seen so
by finally showing us a different
universe and a cameo of another
character from that Universe that'll
increase the hype for the MCU overall
and the Multiverse Saga and what's to
come Deadpool 3 and Avengers Secret Wars
and of course that will start to
increase the hype for Avengers Secret
Wars starting to different variants
finally come into these movies so
overall it's really not a bad plan for
Marvel Studios to do this switch up the
ending throw in a cameo get people
talking about it of course the only
question that we have right now is which
Cameo is it going to be what exactly is
this ending going to be we are pretty
sure the ending is most likely still
going to involve an incursion and
somebody going to a different Universe
from there that person will see that
Cameo this makes the most sense because
we haven't really heard anything about
much re-shoot happening for the Marvels
so really just filming one person for
one scene just their little quick Cameo
is ideal because it doesn't take that
much more work it doesn't take that much
more work to add it to the film on top
of the filming of it but it could do a
great deal of good for the Marvels for
Deadpool 3 for Avengers Secret Wars and
for the MCU in general so overall if
this really is what they're doing which
it really does sound like it since three
different insiders have stated they've
all heard this one of which says that
they have seen the change and have now
bought tickets for the movie then this
is a really good idea and it sounds like
it's going to be overall just increasing
the quality of the film but go ahead and
let us know what you think about this in
the comments down below who do you think
this Cameo is going to be who do you
want it to be in a realistic manner but
again like we've said with the
Multiverse literally anything is
possible so let us know your thoughts in
the comments down below please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up to date with the MCU you can
also find us on Instagram and Twitter as
as well and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf
wolof